[Music]
outside the cabin
the team searches for signs in the snow
indicating nickel anko's whereabouts we
started looking for fresh footprints at
once I saw fresh ski tracks leading away
from the cabin nickel anko often used
his skis to traverse this frozen land
and as the men followed the trail they
were enoch elenco
may have fallen victim to advancing age
we thought he might have had an ordinary
heart attack he could have gone
cross-country skiing and the physical
strain was too much for him a quarter of
a mile from the cabin
the search team comes upon a clue what
does moose kill I approached the
riverbank and at once I saw bears
footprints at first I was not even aware
they were a bear's tracks I had never
seen such big footprints before now two
sets of tracks lay before them ski
tracks and bear tracks both heading in
the same direction further along a
disturbance in the snow indicates a
close encounter yeah I saw by their
tracks that the bear came back several
times
a mile and a half into the search the
party makes another discovery at the end
of the tracks we found his skis and his
backpack nickel anko's gear lay at the
edge of an alder patch but the
researcher himself is nowhere to be
found
the search team enters the thick
underbrush makes a grisly discovery the
lifeless body of the tallied nickel anko
clues to his deaths around him including
the tool of his trade for the fog his
camera lay next to him the strap was
torn near by the team finds a can of
bear deterrent in a patch of orange
spray the spray mark was not large it
was concentrated focused on one spot on
the mission field the wounds on his body
went to a swift and deadly clash the
first blow came to the chest and the
second blow was to the head where his
face used to be there was one continuous
wound
the massive trauma points to only one
suspect he was hit twice by a bear